[Musique]
j'ai dû choisir un peu dans mes morceaux
ceux qui parlait d'amour puisque j'ai
fait un disque un peu de blues
ça parle un peu toujours d'amour et de
mort n'a plus ou moins ensemble ou
séparément ce le gall donc là et on va
faire un morceau qui s'appelle chis aide
c'est un peu l'histoire d'un gars sort
d'une femme qui est marié à cette femme
en sait pas trop ce n'est pas forcément
au top gun autobiographique ce fameux le
dit mais il faut que tu arrêtes tes
chansons à la con quoi de la fougue de
gagner du blé font vraiment j'ai des
rêves j'ai des trucs moi je pensais
qu'en épousant un artiste
j'aurai une belle maison et plein de
choses du coup il faut que tu fasses un
peu d des émissions télé mais soir les
petits fasse un peu plus fréquente les
bonnes personnes qui prennent des
drogues avec des personnes importantes à
pékin tout ça et puis en gros cette
chanson ça parle un peu de ça avec voilà
2 3 punchline assez connue donc si je la
faisais que la cm texte anglais fait
qu'un délicieux accent francophone
vous comprendrez quand même le texte
pour une fois donc ce morceau s'appelle
schiste
[Musique]
hé hé
et
me
[Musique]
mais
tiens
ce canal
[Musique]
et
c
[Musique]
et
mais qui
il
[Musique]
sa mini
et
[Musique]
oui
kim et
[Musique]
il
jiwa
et
[Musique]
défi
m
et qui
mais
[Musique]
il est une
il est
m
[Musique]
et
il
mais
et
[Musique]
bon
le 2 mai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en fait joué pour des gens ainsi ça fait
plus sérieux un peu plus ferme et un
mini montre c'est cool c'est tout ça une
espèce de cocktail dînatoire c'est comme
si j'allais recevoir un prix enfin tout
ça fait un peu des victoires les
défaites de la musique comme j'aime bien
les appeler bon bref je parle beaucoup
mais parce que j'ai l'occasion et les
autres et souvent il m'empêche de le
faire donc j'en profite
moi qui décide donc fâche un morceau
s'appelle ça a vraiment un truc quand au
classique blues c'est my baby gone
voilà c'est tiré
[Musique]
le même
je
[Musique]
c'est
et
[Musique]
sûrement
il
[Musique]
g
et
[Musique]
il
et
[Musique]
il
on va voir les fois qu'on aime c'est dur
aussi dernier morceau c'est un peu
l'histoire de c'est un gars qui décide
de quitter sa compagne et à l'est pas du
tout d'accord
et elle décide de le faire tuer par un
tueur à gages pourquoi pas un remarque
elle la plume personne d'autre lara est
en fait lui ça lui plaît pas monstre
normal trop vénère et en fait après
qu'il a été tué revient et il a en tête
devraient pas dépenser avant ou
[Musique]
ça les rigolos dit comme ça en fait
évidemment triste
[Musique]
où
et
kim et moi et m
[Musique]
wen
où
[Musique]
ce monde là
m
c'est rien
dans chic
[Musique]
c'est ouvert
et
[Musique]
chaud
et
lee
il
via
il n'avait pas de situer
et
[Musique]
des crétins
tu as lu
pippa
[Musique]
où
ces eaux
d'enchaîner
[Musique]
et
chez nous
[Musique]
et
il
utile
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
et
non
on
mais
non
oui
[Musique]
une
et
où
m
[Musique]
[Musique]
oh
il y
[Musique]
il
mais
[Musique]
nouveau
n
il
[Musique]
on
utilisez tout le temps qu'ils perdent
active rsa dont 22 secondes
c'est un peu comme quand on loue une
voiture c'est mieux de la la rendre avec
le plein en fait on est gagnant
un simple
on
oh et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci alberton oeuvre s'il vous plaît
beaucoup d'amour cette love
voici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]